go to bed tonight you could come over
and can make a good impression on my
pillow okay ready
we're back okay okay here are the
questions from the people who wrote in
what explains Ben Carson's rise in the
polls good question
yeast well he's the swamp spoke and
Donald Trump I mean let's not forget ben
Carson is super crazy we did it we did
an editor a couple years ago by the
phenomenon what I call smart stupid
people like I mean somehow he's a
brilliant neurosurgeon who believes the
world is 5,000 years old I mean as long
as I live I will never understand that
that divide in people's minds how you
can be brilliant and a total [ __ ]
idiot at the same time he had to use a
press conference today from burden I was
watching this and he was very fluid and
very smart and got this guy's really
clever and there's a part in the press
conference where I remember that he
compared America current 2015 America to
Nazi Germany and when given the chance
to walk this back he said no it's it's
pretty much like Nazi Germany I was like
these are rid of this guy he also
believes Obama's a psychopath who may
cancel the election he said that uh and
by the way I saw that same press
conference today he this is so typically
Republican he said you know I didn't
really get the immigration issue till I
went to the border and I saw there was a
hole in the fence and you know people
could come right through it's like that
is so Reagan asked to take one anecdotal
moment actually Obama has done more than
any other president to increase border
security really right but this guy sees
one they used to it was Reagan President
Reagan what if I told you and gave you a
jelly bean if you knew and then they
would tell him some anecdotal thing and
he would make policy about it you know
they took him to one place and of course
it's a twenty two thousand mile border
there's going to be a hole in the fence
somewhere and this [ __ ] is gonna make
policy based on the one day he spent
there seeing one hole in one fence okay
well I gotta tell you I think that there
is a real desire in the Republican Party
to have a
a Republican and I think that's part of
what drives that we had Herman Cain last
time around we had alan keyes i there
really is and they there is a real
desire to look like they like a black
Negro because to look like they go on
and then not choose him yeah there it
but it seems to happen every four years
we have a great black hope in the
Republican Party it's the show it's like
so you see we're really not racist it's
not like we don't that you know we don't
hate all black we have a black friend
yeah we have a black friend Salman what
is the what is the state of free speech
in today's liberal societies in 30 words
or less not great
yeah not great but owns twenty eight
woods yeah no and I think I think a lot
of it has to do with PC a lot of it has
to do with you know people accepting the
idea that you shouldn't upset people and
that that should be a limiting point on
speech right that it's on us it's on us
upset if yeah if somebody riots at
Benghazi in twenty other cities because
there was a movie made about the Prophet
then you know that's on you for making
it that's insane it's insane it's there
are plenty of things that upset me you
right yeah I mean like I mean sure see
above Donald Trump right yeah right
upsets me but that doesn't mean I think
he's well actually it does mean I think
he should be you know eradicated but I
try hard to pretend I don't think that
here's a here's a question about Donald
Trump is he gaffe proof um so far I mean
he certainly has rewritten all the rules
of politics because so far he is gaffe
proof do you remember that that I look
back wistfully at that moment weren't he
insulted John McCain and ever and all
the sages were scratching their beards
inside you know he's done he's like I
mean when the Carly Fiorina thing came
out I was again right that's that's
gonna have no effect on him whatsoever
he is it is back to this thing I'd like
people want somebody who's a straight
talker and they don't seem to follow up
with the second step there but this
Straight Talk not be totally bananas
they don't seem to mind that now it is
be honor it reminds me when my old show
politically-incorrect was on about a
year or two people started to imitate it
and so we had a contest called
politically incorrect or just stupid
because people thought they could say
things that were just stupid and that
was politically incorrect when
politically incorrect just meant not
political yes straight talk but it
doesn't mean you veer into stupidity for
no reason well we'll see Michael what
was it like reporting on North Korea
from its border with South Korea oh it
was terrifying in some ways and I was
with a bunch of defectors and miraculous
people people had lost arms trying to
escape and we were launching well I was
there reporting on it they were
launching balloons to send information
to the north and it's an incredible
thing when you realize how quick
somebody can say something here and
there's a pile-on on twitter that's the
sort of you know world we live in now
and in North Korea the only the best way
of getting information to them was
sending it up in a balloon with a bit of
a charge on it that would drop its load
they have no idea where they just hope
somebody gets it and that's how isolated
North Korea is that this is the best
they have another guy that I met had
developed a slingshot literally a
slingshot did with a narrowest point of
the river between China North Korea and
between South Korea and they would fire
USB drives over the river I mean
absolutely insane
a new vice guys have such balls the play
there a lot of military I don't have it
well may you have been advice I'm Dulles
compared to those guys who got it to go
to the border with North Korea you've
got more balls two vice reporters were
arrested for just for repression in
Turkey and one is still under one and
that is an important thing because he's
a fixer yes a journalist and he's a
great fixer and he is because he's
Turkish he's the white guy who's got
released yeah the white guys got
released the air21 government has kept
him and that's its absolute Turkey and
whenever I criticize you did anybody in
the Muslim world they say oh you what
about Turkey what about the moderate
Muslim states like Turkey well well
Turkey's having a very good go at
turning into not a moderate no they
really are that's its plan right
yes their mineral Minister of Health
said women should be mothers and mothers
only their president said women should
not be compared to men it's not fair to
men to men right will Hilary's apology
make any difference to voters no way I
mean they don't trust her but the polls
show that people do not trust Hillary
Clinton she has lost it is in politics
women start out with a kind of reservoir
of trust people tend to think women are
more honest and more ethical she has
lost that but just tell me on what
planet was someone hurt by this email
scandal well we don't know on what
planet someone was hurt because in fact
I don't think it was earth no bill I'm
sorry if in fact she had classified
information that dealt with satellite
what she says she didn't but there are
people in the intelligence community
that said she did and if in fact she had
a server that could be more easily hat
than the government server she could
have done the same people that said it
was classified didn't market as
classified so why did they send it out
unmarked as classified now that he can
do damage she won the secretary now they
can come back and say oh secondarily
yeah but it was it was classified but at
the same time the secretary secretary
Powell said just this weekend he did the
same thing luckily I did some
housekeeping at save Department on my
laptop with my personal in the Clinton
administration and there have been
people in the Obama administration who
have been prosecuted for that you had
jaundice you had sandy burger and you
and you had David Petraeus all of whom
mishandled not anything they gave that's
not stuff that we clearly marked
classified and broke the law David
purchase marking the marking of a
classified information is irrelevant it
had satellite data it had my
to have special compartmented
intelligence clearance I know about this
I was in the White House I handle
classified information it doesn't have
to be marked if it contains satellite
data
you know it's classified and according
to the people who have actually seen the
emails I haven't the people in the
intelligence community say that she had
information in there on North Korea's
nuclear program that was obtained
through satellites she as Secretary of
State had to know this is not the kind
of information that you put in an email
on a server that is in your home and
chip in wherever it is in New York do
you think if it wasn't this fox news
would have found something else or do
you think it's just I think still you
want to know what I see I think the
Republicans would love to run against
Hillary Clinton and I actually agree
that Joe Biden there's something sort of
fresh about him he's right he says what
he believes he says we believe I like
Joe and there's a lot of things you
could say about it but fresh fresh is
not the first word that comes to mind I
don't measure the scale kind of way
right the guy is is you know he doesn't
do what Trump does but he does say
what's on his mind and people like that
fresh like the Kool & the Gang song
Alexandre can Republicans appeal to
young people by championing deregulation
for companies like uber why are you
asking me about a sorry my bike mic
didn't work
oh yeah no do a little stand-up do a
hunk I don't know why your airline honk
come on it's always funny I don't really
know anything about appealing to
Republicans so I don't know how to
answer that question but it is
interesting that the tech companies have
had a free ride cuz they've given so
much money to the Democrats that the
Democrats have left them alone I mean
they have not gotten any use uber no no
no I'm not on Facebook I'm not on
Twitter
I'm not buying in adult I know I'm a
dinosaur I know I don't get Facebook
that's one thing I'm not on but tuber
yeah I mean I did
come on there is there is something
super creepy about them rating you as a
customer you know like if I fart or
don't talk enough that's something super
Krete you you must use them in yeah but
they ask you as you get out would you
please give me a five star rating right
well this is the equivalent of like like
me every TV show like it's on today I
give everybody a five star rating at the
coming rod they know where I live beside
we do good Drive thank you very much
ladies
you
you